il va bientôt être sous le feu des
projecteurs ce soit de philippe le bel
va être photographiés sur tous les
angles derrière l'objectif jean-bernard
l'un des photographes des archives
départementale des yvelines
les équipes s'occupent en ce moment d'un
ensemble d'une trentaine de sault ses
cachets officiels apposés sur des actes
pour les authentifier et les fermer pour
garantir le secret fait une photo du
sceau recto verso avec le parchemin qui
lui est propre et ensuite je je fais des
photos du détail du sceau de manière à
pouvoir appuyer sur les endroits où ça a
été restauré ou la cire et les
différentes des couleurs sont
différentes
et puis et pouvoir me faire des plans un
peu plus cirer sur les écritures de
manière à pouvoir les déchiffrer de
manière un peu plus facile aux archives
ils sont quatre à officier autour de la
numérisation des manipulations délicate
depuis la fin des années 90 pour
sauvegarder des trésors historiques
comme cette carte de chasse datant du
xviiie siècle ou encore ces journaux le
problème de la presse aujourd'hui c'est
que ce sont des supports de papier
relativement incidents qui peuvent
casser au bout de quelques années et
c'est vraiment la priorité aujourd'hui
de pouvoir les sauvegardes et pour les
générations futures
là toutes les archives de presse locale
était conservé dans un dépôt légal au
niveau de la préfecture de chaque
département
malheureusement donc il n'ya pas de
dépôt légal comme aujourd'hui les grands
titres de presse nationaux à la
bibliothèque nationale
du coup il ya eu un vrai travail
actuellement de numérisation et de
sauvetage
finalement de cette tresse qui est
conservée aux archives départementales
mais hélas le dépôt légal n'étaient pas
conservés dans les meilleures conditions
voir été très lacunaires 7 à 9% défauts
sont aujourd'hui numérisés le prochain
projet ces cinq volumes de l'abrégé de
l'histoire de france
l'histoire des rois de france écrit par
le cardinal de fleury précepteur du
jeune louis 15 un travail de sauvegarde
pour éviter de manipuler trop souvent
ces archives mais aussi un travail de
partage et de transmission
certains de ces documents sont
accessibles aux internautes à travers le
site des archives aujourd'hui pour une
personne qui rentre en salle vous
avait à peu près 600 qui vont sur le
site internet
alors ce qui intéresse le plus
aujourd'hui nos citoyens malgré la très
grande richesse de nos fonds c'est
évidemment les sources généalogiques
c'est à peu près 60% de notre lectorat
qu'on a appelé un moment il est gêné à
notre à côté vous avez aussi des
documents qui sont plutôt liés à
l'histoire foncière notamment le
cadastre avec les matrices cadastrales
qui permet vraiment de faire l'histoire
en fait de sa maison d'un terrain et si
vous aussi vous vous laissiez tenter en
se baladant dans les fichiers de l'état
civil ou peut notamment découvrir l'acte
de naissance de jacques tatischeff né le
9 octobre 1907 opecst un certain jacques
tati